C'est une question de Nathan : Quelles sont les preuves de l'existence de Dieu ?
Yo c'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de Ask, la série où c'est vous qui posez les questions,
et merci Nathan pour ta question. Alors je vais vous parler de cinq preuves de l'existence de Dieu
alors c'est pas un top 5, c'est juste cinq preuves que j'aime bien.
Je précise tout de suite, quand je parle de Dieu je parle pas d'un monsieur barbu, qui nous regarde,
qui est omniscient, avec qui on pourrait rentrer en contact, etc.
Dieu ça peut être aussi, par exemple, une substance transcendante, éternelle, infinie,
cause d'elle même et qui est en tout, un petit peu comme genre la Force dans Star Wars quoi.
Bref du coup ne vous bloquez pas sur cette image de Dieu, cette vidéo n'a rien à voir avec les religions,
les prophètes, les dogmes, etc.
On va juste parler de l'existence de Dieu, du concept de dieu et sous toutes ses formes.
Descartes a énoncé plusieurs preuves de l'existence de Dieu dans les Méditations Métaphysiques
et il y en a une que j'aime bien, en fait il part de l'idée d'infini, voilà on a tous cette idée d'infini en nous,
de manière innée, or on est fini, nous-même on est fini,
autour de nous, tout ce qui nous entoure est fini, tous ce qu'on expérimente est fini
donc comment ça se fait qu'on ait cette idée d'infini en nous ?
Et en fait Descartes explique ça par une entité qui aurait mis cette idée d'infini en nous,
et qui est elle-même, du coup, infinie. Du coup, bah cette entité c'est Dieu.
Le problème de cet argument, c'est qu'il dit qu'on a l'idée d'infini en nous,
Sauf que John Locke, par exemple, n'est absolument pas d'accord, et moi non plus
(d'ailleurs je vous l'avez dit sur Snapchat pour ceux qui me suivent),
en gros, c'est pas vraiment l'idée d'infini qu'on a en nous, c'est l'idée du non-fini, c'est-à-dire qu'on fait une négation
de l'idée de la finitude.
C'est pas exactement pareil tu vois, on n'arrive pas à appréhender complètement l'infini
tu vois t'arrives pas à penser vraiment l'infini. Par contre tu penses, t'arrives à penser
quelque chose qui n'est pas fini.
Et c'est différent tu vois, il y a une nuance.
Alors c'est pas une étourderie ou un oubli de Descartes, lui il pensait vraiment qu'on pense l'infini, hein,
il le dit même dans son livre,
je vous parle pas du non-fini, mais je parle vraiment de l'infini,
à la manière où on pense le repos et pas seulement l'absence de mouvement,
à la manière où on pense l'obscurité, et pas seulement l'absence de lumière, etc,
mais voilà pour l'infini en tout cas je suis plutôt d'accord avec John Locke, c'est-à-dire qu'on pense le non-fini
et en fait l'idée de fini est une idée simple
(quand je parle d'idée simple, je fais une référence à la vidéo sur John Locke, je vous la mets dans la description),
on va nier cette idée simple de fini, pour donner ce non-fini.
Du coup, vu que tout le raisonnement repose sur le fait qu'on est l'idée d'infini... [onomatopée intranscriptible]
bah ça marche plus.
Alors ça c'est un argument Ontologique, hein, il n'y en a pas qu'un. Un argument ontologique c'est un argument
où pour prouver l'existance de Dieu, on va prendre la définition de l'être de Dieu.
Saint Anselme, il part du fait qu'on a l'idée de Dieu dans la tête.
Jusque là pas de problèmes, on a tous déjà pensé à Dieu.
Ensuite il dit que Dieu pourrait exister dans la réalité,
il n'y a pas de contradictions intrinsèques à l'idée de Dieu qui l'empêcheraient d'exister.
Et ensuite il nous explique qu'une idée, elle est forcément plus forte
plus grande, plus importante.. si elle existe aussi dans la vie réèlle.
Du coup si Dieu n'existe pas dans le monde réèl,
ça voudrait dire que son idée pourrait être encore plus grande et plus forte.
Or c'est pas possible
parce que c'est Dieu et que Dieu ne peut pas être plus grand ou plus fort
donc il ne peut pas exister seulement dans ton esprit
et vu qu'il existe dans ton esprit
ça veut dire qu'il existe dans ton esprit
et dans le monde réel
Là aussi on pourrait revenir sur cette preuve avec Kant par exemple
qui nous dit que, bah, Dieu existe
"Dieu existe" c'est une tautologie
c'est redire la même chose
Si je prends Dieu comme postulat de départ
son existence fait partie constituante de ce qu'il est
Kant donne un exemple plus simple
l'exemple du triangle, si on suppose un triangle
on ne va pas affirmer qu'il n'a pas d'angles
parce que quand on s'est posé triangle on a établi qu'il avait trois angles
Quand Saint-Anselme dit que Dieu
ne peut pas être plus fort et plus grand
bah, ouais, mais c'est la définition même de Dieu
donc c'est un petit peu le serpent qui se mord la queue.
donc en fait c'est pas vraiment une preuve.
ça arrive que quand tu demandes l'origine de l'univers à quelqu'un
il va te dire : "voilà c'est comme ça, l'univers a toujours été là"
C'est un peu che-lou
Moi quand je me promène en forêt
que je trouve un caillou par terre
et que je dis : "D'où vient ce caillou ?"
si quelqu'un me répond : "Bah, il a toujours été là"
tu vois ça fait un peu che-lou
Et ben imagine ce caillou, tu l'agrandis, agrandis
il devient énorme, énorme, énorme
et c'est l'univers
la même question se pose
C'est pas parce que l'univers est énorme et qu'on est dedans
qu'il n'y a pas une cause première
En 2003 le mathématicien Borde
et les physiciens Guth et Vilenkin
nous disent que n'importe quel univers
en expansion (donc visiblement, le nôtre)
heu, ne peut pas être infini au passé
et donc : a un début
Il y a aussi le théorème de Penrose Hawking
qui va dans ce sens en mettant en évidence
un instant zéro de l'univers
Donc il y a un début de l'univers
donc il y a quelque chose qui a engendré ce début
et ce quelque chose, cette cause
elle est forcément dans une réalité
qui est au-delà de l'univers
qui est transcendante à l'univers
elle est au-delà de l'espace temps
parce que l'origine de l'univers ne peut pas être dans l'univers.
Donc, on a une cause qui est nécessaire
qui ne peut pas ne pas être
qui engendre une entité contingente
c'est-à-dire qui pourrait ne pas être
cette entité, c'est l'univers
Du coup on se retrouve face à une cause nécessaire
qui peut créer l'univers ou ne pas créer l'univers
En gros on parle de quelque chose qui a la liberté de le faire
ou non, on parle de quelque chose
qui peut créer l'univers par sa volonté
on parle Dieu.
Le problème de cette preuve réside surtout
dans cette idée de début de l'univers en fait
parce que c'est le postulat de base
et il n'est pas prouvé.
Aujourd'hui quand on ébauche un modèle
pour unifier la théorie de la relativité générale
et la physique quantique
et qu'on applique ce modèle
à la description de l'univers primordial
c'est-à-dire à l'univers d'il y a très très longtemps
Et bin, ce qui serait le point d'origine de l'univers
soit il s'évanouit
soit il se déplace dans le temps
il s'éloigne
et à chaque fois.
Donc aujourd'hui on n'a pas la preuve scientifique
que l'univers a une origine
et on n'a pas non plus la preuve qu'il n'en a pas.
La théorie des mondes possibles
c'est une théorie surtout philosophique
qui dit qu'il y auraient d'autres mondes avec d'autres logiques que les nôtres
ça n'a rien à voir avec la théorie des multivers en physique
La théorie des mondes possibles dit par exemple
qu'il y a un monde possible où cette figure existe
il y a un monde où les licornes existent
et donc, il y a un monde où Dieu existe.
Or, si Dieu existe dans un monde,
alors il existe dans tous, car Dieu est un être infini
maximal, transcendant
Et donc s'il existe dans tous les mondes
et bin il existe aussi dans le nôtre
Cette preuve entre nous
moi le raisonnement je le trouve sympa
mais elle est un peu pourrie hein
Je l'ai mise dans le lot, parce que 5 ça faisait un chiffre cool
mais si tu veux elle part quand même du principe
qu'il y a un monde
où il y a une licorne et Superman
qui sont en train de se prendre une pinte
Pour ceux qui veulent en savoir plus sur les mondes possibles
je vous envoie vers les travaux de David Lewis
mais voilà c'est un petit peu
aberrant quoi, je trouve.
J'pense que même Dieu il n'y croit pas
Vous avez tous déjà vu Matrix
l'idée c'est qu'on est tous ensemble
dans une simulation informatique
on est tous ensemble, j'exagère même
si ça se trouve vous êtes tout seul
dans une simulation informatique
Tout autour de nous pourrait être simulé
et donc on serait dans un programme informatique géant
et aujourd'hui il n'y a rien
aucune preuve qui permette de réfuter
cette théorie
Or, si cette théorie est vraie
bah forcément, Dieu existe
parce que ça voudrait dire que
il y a quelque chose qui a
créé notre monde,
qui est transcendant
et que notre monde est régi par cette chose.
Bah, c'est un peu la définition de Dieu.
Voilà, le seul truc c'est qu'on peut pas prouver ou réfuter
qu'on n'est pas dans une simulation mais sinon
euh... il n'y a rien à dire
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
sur la même thématique je vais essayer de sortir
incessamment sous peu
un Coup de Phil sur le Pari de Pascal
et j'essaye de vous sortir un nouveau programme là
ça fait, aller, 9 mois que j'y réfléchis
ça murit doucement
Là ça fait 4 mois
je me penche sur une identité graphique
... sonore, un nom surtout
Un nom surtout, qui me plait !
Et je pense avoir trouvé ! Et là je travaille
je fais les finitions et tout
Donc voilà, ça va arriver bientôt
et je ferai une vidéo pour vous présenter
ce que c'est
il est possible aussi que je mette une autre preuve
au moins un début de preuve en tout cas, je ne sais pas
on va en discuter ensemble
sur Facebook, sur ma page Facebook
Et euh... suivez là aussi
puisqu'il va y avoir une annonce de live bientôt
N'hésitez pas à poser d'autres questions
sur Facebook, Twitter
ou dans les commentaires de la vidéo
il est possible que je fasse une vidéo sur les 5 preuves de la non-existence de Dieu
mais c'est pas sûr.
Je verrai, ça dépend.
En tout cas j'espère que ça vous a plus, encore une fois
Et .... Ciao !